situación muy tensa en belgor donde las
autoridades rusas se han visto obligadas
a evacuar varias ciudades horas después
de la que se considera que es la
incursión por tierra más ambiciosa de
las fuerzas ucranianas desde que empezó
La Guerra de Ucrania gran escala hace 15
meses en la zona se ha decretado la
alerta antiterrorista lo que supone que
las comunicaciones están intervenidas y
también está restringida la movilidad de
la población el presidente Vladimir
Putin ha sido puntualmente informado de
todos los acontecimientos Aunque desde
el kremming se ha tratado de minimizar
lo ocurrido asegurando que se trata de
un intento de los ucranianos de tapar lo
que supone políticamente la pérdida de
la ciudad de basmut sabemos algo más
sobre lo que está pasando en verbo por
ejemplo varios drones supuestamente
ucranianos han sido derribados por los
sistemas antiaéreos rusos mientras
sobrevolaban esta parte de Rusia y
también aunque se había dicho que sólo
había heridos parece que se produjo una
víctima mortal durante la tarde del
lunes durante la evacuación precisamente
de esas ciudades rusas cercanas a la
frontera ucraniana